i don't think there's any value
to the public
in having a circuit court judge explain
the intricacies of a judicial opinion
which really only law school graduates
can comprehend
a lot of times i made decisions on the
bench that the law forced me to make
that i sent people to jail
for crimes that in my opinion were
victimless and shouldn't have been
crimes and they should not have gone to
jail like the
three strikes on possession of marijuana
he went away for 20 years that's so
absurd especially today where it's legal
in 37 states but there are times when
judges must do things that they don't
want to do because they've taken an oath
to uphold the law and the law requires
it
explaining that
so that the public can understand it is
a very
difficult task
all right so let's let's shift to a
couple of the other things going on
right now so obviously uh joe biden has
selected katanji brown jackson to be his
nominee for the supreme court
i have no doubt that this once the the
hearings begin will be as chaotic as
ever maybe not quite as chaotic as brett
kavanaugh because she's kind of on the
side of the media but you know the usual
stuff is going to happen um i guess a
uh what would your general
qualifications be i think i have a sense
of that already and b how do we pull for
some truth out of this knowing that the
media is not going to cover it the way
it would if say she was nominated by
donald trump or a republican president
i start with the premise that under the
constitution the president gets to
nominate whoever he wants and believe it
or not dave
neither the constitution nor federal law
require that a supreme court justice
even be a lawyer
much less uh held prior judicial
experience
the last justice who didn't even
graduate from law school was justice
robert jackson who had been the attorney
general of the united states under fdr
and he's one of the most quotable
justices
uh in the modern era
never graduated from law school today of
course uh the senate would not confirm
anyone who didn't graduate from law
school
uh the senate and the presidents seem to
prefer
people who have judicial experience
that's not required
at all
chief justice earl warren
had no judicial experience and probably
affected
jurisprudence in this country more than
anybody chief justice john marshall the
great chief justice from the thomas
jefferson to the andrew jackson years he
had no judicial experience
and because joe biden nominated her
she's a liberal democrat that's to be
expected
donald trump i'm very familiar with his
nomination process
i was intimately involved the first time
around
donald trump in my opinion
nominated two conservatives and one
libertarian libertarian is neil gorsuch
uh the conservatives are amy coney
barrett as a graduate of the same law
school as i am university of notre dame
uh and uh and brett kavanaugh that's the
president's
uh prerogative
i don't agree with senator lindsey
graham and many things but i agree with
him on this the president nominated the
person and he or she is basically
qualified i'm going to vote for them i
think that's what the outcome will be
with judge
katanchi brown jackson however
there are a conservative republicans on
the judiciary committee and i know them
both well ted cruz has been a friend of
mine for years
josh hawley i we have met through the
monitor like you and i are meeting now
uh they're going to go for her jugular
they're going to find
decisions that she made which she
believes she was compelled to make under
the law which appear inexplicable
uh to the public
not to hurt her not to deny her the the
job because she'll certainly get it
but to embarrass the president
this uh you know this started with
robert bork
and it was joe biden
here with clarence thomas
um and then of course uh brett kavanaugh
it doesn't happen to all of them it
didn't happen amy coney barrett it did
not happen to ruth bader ginsburg it did
not happen to neil gorsuch but every
once in a while there is a nominee
that the minority party that's the party
that's not in the white house
thinks they can tarnish
the person who did the nomination by
tarnishing
uh the candidate history has shown
that does not carry over into the
nominees
judicial opinions
whatever you think of of clarence thomas
he is either forgiven or forgotten and
the same thing with uh with brett
kavanaugh robert of work of course the
trashing worked uh he was uh rejected by
a vote of 52 against and 48 in favor
yeah which joe biden basically led the
charge on do you think that there's some
do you think that there's some value in
say ted cruz josh hawley some of these
other guys
going for the jugular even if she's
going to be confirmed either way just to
to at least expose some of the thinking
behind the decisions so that people can
frame the issues properly even if they
can't stop it even though and of course
it becomes a certain amount either way
so the political i think the values to
the political base yeah most
respectfully to my friends
uh for uh ted cruz uh and uh josh hawley
i don't think there's any value
to the public
in having a circuit court judge explain
the intricacies of a judicial opinion
which really only law school graduates
uh can comprehend a lot of times i made
decisions on the bench that the law
forced me to make
that i sent people to jail
for crimes that in my opinion were
victimless and shouldn't have been
crimes and they should not have gone to
jail like the
three strikes on possession of marijuana
he went away for 20 years that's so
absurd especially today where it's legal
in 37 states but there are times when
judges must do things that they don't
want to do because they've taken an oath
to uphold the law and the law requires
it explaining that
so that the public can understand it is
a very
difficult task what about if the judge
was truly radical and i i honestly don't
know enough about her her full resume
and obviously we're going to hear it but
what if they were someone that really
did not hold any of the principles that
you mentioned at the beginning about our
founding documents and individual rights
and they really were activists in terms
of they wanted to fundamentally change
the way the the country is run you'd
you'd want some exploratory version of
it right the answer is yes however with
uh with judge jackson i mean she was
confirmed to the united states district
court eight years ago
and then was confirmed by this very same
senate to the circuit court of appeals
one year ago
so they've already gone through all this
however if if um if some uh nominee did
not believe
that the constitution was the supreme
law of the land or believe that the
declaration of independence was just
jefferson's musings
or that the first amendment really
doesn't guarantee the freedom of speech
that person would probably be
disqualified and those views should be
exposed if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversation about
law instead of the non-stop yelling you
get everywhere else check out our law
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell